Scot zou lack former quarterback in the
NFL
Patriots radio color analyst joining us
on the program Scott how are you this
morning
good Dan I guess you and I are the only
two left
working here at the end of the week is
uh we head to the break and let's go
Hawks on Sunday night's football beat
those teeth huh let me ask you about the
Patriots in the product that's gonna be
on the field for the next two games and
then the postseason is there any chance
that Belichick can bring in a wide
receiver to you know not fill the void
but at least you got another receiver
there with Josh Gordon suspended no I
don't think so I don't think so and I
think the guy that actually takes his
place is Phillip Dorsett of guides been
here and has played well T in the last
year especially through the playoff run
yeah he knows the system at this point
you're not bringing in any guy that's
going to be able to get on the same page
with Brady you know and they've they've
worked you know around the clock to get
Josh up and going and hey at lasted 11
weeks you know and as the statement read
we sort of knew that this was possible
with Josh that he could walk away at any
time given what he's gone through
I'm anokhin and I'm not expert and in
mental health and I would never evaluate
Josh and what he's went through I was
fortunate enough to be brought up at a
good household and we all know what Josh
went through and it's hard to comment on
that but when he was here he talking
everybody and knowing Tom as well as I
do and Tom worked tirelessly with him to
get him up and going and I think Josh
gave him everything he could but I think
it's Phillip Dorsett here how vulnerable
are the Patriots it's a good question
Dan I mean we got we have Buffalo here
one o'clock on on Sunday we finished it
up with the Jets here one o'clock the
following weekend and I mean if it all
true we should be 11 and 5 I've called
games for this team on 12 and 4 seasons
when we won our deep Super Bowl runs and
and one thing but as you know in this
league every team is different this 11
and 5 teams say they end up 11 if five
doesn't feel the same way you know that
that 12 and 14 did but you know you look
at the rest of this league and you look
at the struggles the Saints had the
other night you know the Rams the Chiefs
on during prime time games
I think it's wide open I think the
mindset of the Patriots
right now is to get in this thing and
the coach quarterback combination
hopefully will help you as you move
forward regardless of who you play is
there scenario where you see this being
Brady's last season if they win the
whole damn thing and get in this thing
and go on some monstrous run yeah and I
said the same thing last year yeah I do
drew yeah yeah I talked to you at the
same time last year I said the same damn
thing that and it almost happened you
know 505 510 yards whatever it was
against Philly and whoever had that ball
last is gonna win that game and if it
ended that way and saved the tight end
almost could have also walked off if
retirement was true to his plans as he
said it was all last offseason so yeah I
mean guys the mindset of guys could
change in this league at anytime
but I real quickly I do know that the
stuff I talked to you with this time
last year a lot of those those
situations where the internal drama has
been buried you know with this trainer
being around and Tom tom is happy right
now
I look at Gronk and I don't know if if
Gronk gets healthier it just feels like
this is what Gronk is going to be I mean
like chronic it's not gone it chronic is
what it should be when you look at he
just looks
he just looks unhealthy he looks hurt he
looks almost he looks older than Brady
does I think a lot of people feel that
way they really do and you know tom is
doing I think everything can to hang in
a pocket you also combine that with some
issues that that woman's going through
whether it's the knee the foot you know
he got dinged up over the last course of
a couple weeks and combine all that
together it makes clonk look worse than
Gronk probably actually feels I'm with
you I think he's a little bit of a shell
of himself right now if I said you had
to make a bet
they either go though you know what
don't cover him though cover him 101 see
what happens yeah oh I know they do
double cover him they the referees in is
in the NFL or I don't know they they
referee the game differently for him but
it is what it is that's what happens
when you're six seven all right if I
said you had to make a bet that the
Patriots lose their first playoff game
or they go to the Super Bowl
come on call it call it play call it
games for this D skin
tell me where two games at where's the
game if the games at home they don't
lose it
no matter who they faced the Patriots
with a face they do not lose an AFC
championship game at home even though
even though Baltimore came up here a
couple of years back and beat them okay
where do you think they're most
vulnerable if they have to play on the
road if they played in Kansas City if
they played in Texas I don't think Texas
I think they match up well with Houston
and I think the coaching matchup matches
well for them like it's a lot of the
same players they know Houston I've been
talking about the Chargers for the last
seven weeks and nobody listened to me
Philip Rivers has washed up they play in
the soccer stadium that would be an odd
venue if we had to go and play the
twenty-eight thousand seat soccer
stadium for an AFC title game where
actually a lot of your your fan base
would travel to and probably take over
that stadium that'd be interesting but I
think Kansas City's difficult difficult
place to play Scott I know you've got
your show coming up thanks for spending
some time and good luck in the playoffs
merry Christmas to you appreciate it
same to you dance at me live always
appreciate it thanks but that's cazzo
like former quarterback he's the color
analyst for the Patriots on 98.5 the
Sports Hub there in Boston for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]